so help me understand because like you
came up and freestyled
and that was about two years ago yeah
i didn't know you would just told me
that you were like you were like around
during the beginning of the young
california yeah yeah
so we can get into it so um kind of give
me yeah give me give me all that your
background like your journey
so basically bro i uh i always been like
doing music i was playing ball and doing
music
after high school i realized i didn't
want to go to college
right it was just like something i
didn't want to do i'm not someone fit
for a school setting
so i was like i'm gonna do music
full-time and i
i gained like popularity in my community
very fast in like the pittsburgh antioch
area
so you ever heard of young curt yeah
i was like the label that
pushed young curt okay so it was me it
was kurt it was young d
it was a bunch of us and i was kind of
more so playing the
the executive role and kurt was the
artist so i had to stop rapping
i'm being his hype man at certain shows
doing certain meetings and everything
like that to where i was just in
executive mode
so we kind of had a falling out and i
went back to doing music that's when i
met amen
knick-knack and everything and we had
came together i never forget this day it
was at pf
change in emeryville it was me amen
charisma
starting six young murph bobby brackens
and i am
soup right wow pilo too and we were
starting this thing called young
california and it was going to be like a
label where we all collabed and did
music and everything
and what happened was about a few weeks
to maybe a month
later beat the [ __ ] up just
shut the [ __ ] out of the [ __ ] world
just it just
just went out the [ __ ] world and that
brought a lot of exposure to the bay
it brought a lot of publicity a lot of
publishers started coming out a lot of
these big brands started coming out
and hbk was at the forefront of that
because they had
the um they had that was really a sue
record too by the way it was a sue
record that
i mean if you didn't want to be uh he
didn't want the record
sue was like a real lyrical rapper at
the time he was tripping by the way
like he was a real world sue was rapping
on [ __ ] like jay electronica exhibit c
[ __ ] [ __ ] like that right so he
didn't want it to be looked at like he
was trying to make
like a yeah like he a sellout record so
he let rents take the record
and rance was a party promoter so ranch
is going to all the parties every
[ __ ] night grabbing the mic
playing this [ __ ] over and over and over
and over right and it just shoots the
[ __ ] up
right so it brings a lot of attention to
the bait now you got
50 cent getting on the record t.i and
jeezy and pleasure p
and chris brown shout out to jay
valentine who put that together
that jay valentine remix the one i play
yeah yeah that's my dog shout out big
bro so
a lot of that had happened and a lot of
the artists under that kind of got lost
in the sauce because we just didn't have
what hbk had going on and it was
their time to shine so hbk
took off and um i kind of started
noticing like
they was getting bigger than the bay
right and then you started seeing like g
come out g eazy comes and then he's
taking everybody on tour you know what i
mean he's
bringing sue he's bringing jay in he's
bringing neff to pharaoh so now we're
starting to get recognition
but it was certain artists who was
getting those looks that wasn't the
people i just named but they were
hitting the ceiling
and i always noticed they would hit this
cylinder get a record they go to
petaluma do shows get a couple thizzler
posts
do a couple summer jams and it was over
there was never nothing after that but
sue and g and everybody that [ __ ] was
still going and i noticed it was gone
because they wasn't just
staying in the bay you know i mean they
started moving around and doing
different things
so um at the time i was like
you know doing a little bass [ __ ] you
know we all do scams and
little things that we was doing to get
money saved up enough money and i moved
to la
and the minute i moved here i realized
for the type of music i wanted to make
i wasn't good enough so i met
phonics who had me around like while
he's making no role models for j
cole i'm going to sessions with hit
maker while he's writing
ray schremer hits and just like all
these big ass songs and i'm like oh [ __ ]
all i can do is rap i can't write a hook
i don't know how to structure a song but
if you put on the instrumental
i'ma flame this [ __ ] right and
um it wasn't until i met somebody
around almost around the time when i met
you
the homie d brooks who um is from
chicago does a lot of work with like
dirk and herbo and everybody
and he kind of was the first the first
person to put it in perspective for me
like bro
a lot of your raps is hooks you could
take this part make it the hook
you know what i mean you can move this
over here you could do this and i
started learning how to structure [ __ ]
but then the problem i started having
was i would hear something
and try to duplicate it so one day i'd
be a rapper
and the next day i hear some future [ __ ]
going up and i'm like this is what they
want
i think that's what a lot of people get
sucked into man yeah
they they they i mean that's dope that
you admit that because a lot of artists
get wrapped up in that it's easy to
super easy especially if you consume
music as a fan you're like
you're waking up every [ __ ] thursday
night at 9 00 p.m or in the morning and
you're looking at the new
[ __ ] music that drops right it's very
hard not to be influenced by it and you
see this [ __ ]
you see it like okay this is what the
[ __ ] works well [ __ ] let me try it let
me do this you know what i mean and then
you try it and it don't work
it's not it's not organic it's not
organic right so what i realized by
doing that
i wasn't developing an identity for
myself
so i had to sit back bro and i really
had to think like what is it i want to
do
it's around the time i had met you in
head when y'all had brought me up there
and that goes to show
how real y'all is as djs right right
and not even just dj's just culture
curators to bring somebody who's trying
to figure it out
up there with no record no nothing is
just like [ __ ] the kid could rap let him
come up here yeah you know what i mean
so i appreciate that
but um around that time i started
figuring out like what i really do
great is rap right and i met my homie
cass that you met yeah my producer
he went out to eat and he had two videos
up of me i had this song
out one time where i was singing and
another song where i was rapping
and he put him on two phones and he
asked me which one are you
right and i said i'm the rapper and he
was like then why are you singing
i'm like well that's what people told me
that's what they like to hear
and he looked at me and he said man i'll
never run from rap
don't ever run from rap you too good of
a rapper to run from rap
and ever since that day uh running from
rap to me
started meaning it's the first time i
ever said this publicly
is don't run from responsibilities and
principles
right i had a responsibility as a rapper
you know what i mean to be dope and to
be great at that
that's the gift i was given but i'm
running away from it
to try to chase chase what other
people's things is so i'm basing
my values and my expectations based off
what other people was getting rather
than just living in my own truth of what
i am yeah
and the minute i started doing that bro
it was like [ __ ] start clicking
i started realizing like okay i don't
want to be somebody in the streets let
me make a song about that
you know what i mean i don't want to be
selling drugs and scamming my whole life
let me make a song about that
and that's how i started developing a
consistent message and the identity of
what i'm standing on as far as growth
and as a man of doing something
different than what we all are supposed
to do as black men growing up in
impoverished communities